we're really delighted today welcome
Gidon Bromberg the co-founder and
Israeli co-director
Pease middle east as the speaker for the
coca-cola will found luxury L so the
coca-cola lecture was founded in 1992 by
the late Roberto Rosetta who was the
former chair and CEO of the coca-cola
company and a class of 1953 member here
oh yeah so you know if you if you go to
Israel on the Middle East as I have one
thing that strikes see you immediately
is that it is a small compact
neighborhood with very scarce resources
and one of the challenges is whether the
scarcity of those resources is going to
be a zero-sum game or whether people can
figure out a decent way to share the
resources and perhaps even use that
sharing process in order to develop
stronger links with each other tonight
speaker Keaton Bromberg has really been
at the heart of trying to figure out
better ways in which you can use
discussions programs developments of how
to share the resources as a way of
bringing people closer together he you
know has worked at eco peace which was
established in 1994 the first
cross-border environmental group in the
Middle East and it has been at the
forefront of measures to try and share
especially the water resources in the
area as a means of bringing people from
across the different communities
together its leadership structure
incorporates people across the
communities and it was instrumental in
2013 in in starting efforts to try and
have water flow again from the Sea of
Galilee to the Jordan River which I
believe you actually achieved in 2015 we
yes yes but a decade's worth of work so
today he's going to speak on the
potential for environmental cooperation
in the region about the politics of
environment in the region
give us hopefully some ideas on ways
forward certainly his own work has
reflected that so welcome you don't
thank you thank you very much Steven and
very grateful to be back here at Yale
with some very familiar faces and I was
a world fellow here in 2007 and had a
fantastic experience here at Yale and
develop the relationships that have
continued until today so we've lost
something okay so I'll be speaking about
innovation in the water sector and the
possibility of that innovation
contributing to peace building and no
other day could be more pertinent to be
speaking about this issue given what's
happening this very day with some 200
rockets falling on Israel I don't know
how many rockets are falling on Gaza and
we have a potential again another Israel
Hamas Islamic Jihad war taking place and
we can just hope that UN and Egyptian
efforts will bring sanity back and and
not see a further escalation of another
round of violence and that's why this
work is so important and these ideas are
so pertinent because we must break the
cycle because the cycle is just more
violence more loss of life and and and
and that just simply can't continue the
price being paid is so horrific lehigh
so echo peace Middle East is indeed 25
years old and there's me 25 years ago
with a bunch of men Egyptians Jordanians
Palestinians and Israelis and the idea
behind echo peace at that time in 94 was
that given the Israel Jordan peace
treaty was signed
and the interim Accords of the Oslo
agreement between Israel and the PLO was
signed
we as environmentalists were concerned
that environment wasn't on the peace
agenda and we were determined to make
sure that peace would not only lead to
peace between people but also with
nature and that was the original raison
D etre of creating echo peace the very
first organization that brought Israelis
Palestinians and Jordanians in fact an
Egyptians at that time Egypt sadly had
to withdraw our Egyptian colleagues and
our officers in Cairo were closed by the
Mubarak regime at some point it was seen
as too dangerous for Egyptians to be
meeting together with Israelis and
scheming together on how to save the
environment and literally our offices in
Cairo were closed and we've never opened
since and today and we're very different
so this is from last week we celebrated
25 years we had 150 people a third
jordanian a third palestinian a third
israeli all come to the shores of the
Dead Sea in Jordan to celebrate 25 years
of echo peace and today it's I'm still
there as the Israeli co-director but
today we have a woman Jana Abu Talib
who's our Jordanian co-director and nada
Mazda Lonnie who's our Palestinian
co-director and what's so unique about
us is that we're 60 staff 20 Palestinian
20 Jordanian 20 Israeli and operating
out of three offices with three
directors every staff person working
with their counterpart in the art in the
other office all for the same common
goal of promoting peace through the
environment the organization has really
been famous for its bottom-up work these
are Israeli and Palestinian kids and
that our youth water trustees on the
Bank side of the river Jordan these are
Jordanian kids on the Jordanian side of
the river Jordan
not much of a river it's only four
kilometers it used to be it's it's only
four meters wide it used to be a hundred
meters wide 95% of the waters of the
Jordan have been taken because of the
conflict and sadly it's no longer fresh
water this is the site according to
Judaism where the Israelites cross to
the promised land this is the site where
John the Baptist and baptizes Jesus
according to the Christian tradition and
there are four companions for the
Prophet Muhammad buried on the banks on
the eastern side yet the fact that half
of humanity sees the river as Holly
hasn't saved the river from the terrible
demise
these are mayors these are Palestinian
Jordanian and Israeli mayors jumping
into the Jordan closer to the Sea of
Galilee so the water the river is wider
here and the water quality is at least
clean fresh water but that's only for
two kilometers they jump into the Jordan
River not because they're best friends
they jump into the Jordan River because
they've come to understand that they're
all losers and they refuse to be losers
and the only way that they can improve
the reality the livelihood of their
residents Palestinian and Jordanian
Israeli is to make a mark is to make a
big splash and they need to do that
together we can go further and this is a
recent photo to show you how far the
organization has gone so the three
directors together with the president of
the UN Security Council in April we were
invited to speak before the UN Security
Council and present our work as an
example of peace building as an example
of the urgency of dealing with climate
change and water insecurity for our
region to help advance security and
peace and to our it was myself and
another Palestinian director the two of
us spoke and the highlight of the whole
event was that after we spoke the
Palestinian ambassador said thank you
echo peace the Israeli and
say Thank You echo peace all the
ambassadors in the Security Council
almost fell on the floor that's not a
common event in fact none of them could
ever remember the Israeli and
Palestinian ambassadors to the UN
Security Council sort of agreeing on
something but very quickly they went
back to their bickering and and the
situation has you know continues to be
what we what we see in the press every
day so when we talk about water resource
issues we're talking about sharing the
Jordan River system and the Jordan River
system starts up in Lebanon in Israel in
Syria and flows down in the Upper Jordan
to the Sea of Galilee leaves the Sea of
Galilee and flows down to the Dead Sea
the lowest place on earth five countries
share the Jordan River Basin Lebanon
Syria Israel Jordan and Palestine so
that's a mate that's the the largest
freshwater body that's our only river in
the region everything else is creeks or
streams we share between Israel and the
West Bank the mountain aquifer which is
the largest groundwater and and and best
quality water for the region and the
Israel and Gaza share the coat the the
coastal aquifer but as ecologist we see
the the map in a completely different
way these are the basins and when you
look at the water basins then of course
the politics makes absolutely no sense
you cannot differentiate between Israel
Palestine Jordan its criss-crossing
of water basins and of course if we're
to manage our environment and our water
is also sustainably we need to be
considering these borders and not the
man-made political borders and I really
want to try and highlight two issues
today and two opportunities and the
first opportunity is to see well at
least what eco peace argues is that
innovation in water technology could
enable us to move forward on an
agreement
on water issues between Israelis and
Palestinians and and that that would be
dramatic
that is the low-hanging fruit perhaps of
all of the final status issues between
Israelis and Palestinians and that is
possible today because of innovation and
then a second point that I'll speak to
is the broader context of climate change
and again innovation in the water sector
but also in the energy sector
particularly the solar energy sector and
the potential of cooperation taking
place on in harnessing the Sun and the
sea to also promote broader cooperation
not only between Israel and Palestine
but Israel Palestine Jordan and the
broader Levant
Middle East and so the technical the the
the technological innovation and in the
water field is predominately led by
Israel and Israel is a world leaders
perhaps the most water efficient country
on Earth
it has decades of experience of drip
irrigation of pricing water right so
that water is a valued resource and
therefore there's a there's a there's an
incentive to conserve water but to
technology stand out and what is the
treatment of sewage and then it's reused
for agriculture so Israel is the world
leader by far and close to 90 percent of
sewage in the country and is treated and
then reused for agriculture Spain is
next in the world
it's about 26% Israel is 90 Jordan comes
very heading for the Arab world at about
16 percent the United States is under
under - so the leadership in in treating
cirrage means that about half the food
produced in Israel is today produced by
treated wastewater and that of course
frees up natural water for other
purposes and then in the last decade
even less the last eight years and
dramatic developments in membrane
technology so the old desalination
which is which you see throughout the
Gulf and cost about two dollars for a
cubic meter of water with membrane
technology in in the in the most modern
Israel today has five desalination
plants the latest desalination plant is
at about 50 cents a cubic meter so it's
a quarter of the cost that can be
cheaper than pumping water from a deep
aquifer so it's a real game-changer and
when you add the two together of course
every additional cubic meter of water
manufactured becomes sewage and then is
treated and reused again so you actually
double the pie by combining both a
desalination and and the treatment of
wastewater and you can see that there's
massive installations and plans for for
tripling so current desalination is
about it's close to 600 million cubic
meters by perspective that's more than
was ever pumped out of the Sea of
Galilee 70% of the drinking water for
the public for the for the population in
Israel today comes from desalination
it's no longer a dependency on natural
water 70 percent and Israel's planning
for her own needs to triple desalination
to 1.8 billion cubic meters annually and
it's not we can talk about it's not
cost-free the energy source at the
moment is fossil and there's also issues
of brine but despite the fact that today
the water pie has it has has expanded
tremendously and we don't see a change
in policy when it comes to Israel and
Palestine and particularly on water
issues so the background here the
context is that under the Oslo Accords
of of 1995 water is seen as a hard issue
to solve because in ninety ninety five
there is only fresh water
when there is only fresh water to depend
on then the reallocation according to
your equitable principles is a difficult
issue to accomplish because it becomes a
win-lose situation where if more water
is transferred to the Palestinians which
needs to take place Israeli farmers
would lose water and therefore water was
left as a final status issue together
with other difficult issues to solve
Jerusalem borders settlements security
refugees with the idea that within five
years a package a deal is struck and one
side will be generous on one issue and
the other side will be generous on the
other issue and that's how the peace
process moves forward so that despite
the fact that innovation has expanded
the pie tremendously we haven't seen a
change any significant change in water
allocation so these are figures of the
Israeli Water Authority from 2014 where
basically of the of the shared mountain
aquifer Palestinians only get 25 percent
of the shared water and Israel maintains
some 75 percent of the shared water and
the ramifications of that is that you
know on every Palestinian home there has
to be a tank because water supply is
intermittent water is not supplied every
day and there isn't enough water for
24/7 water supply in anywhere beard in
in the West Bank and we'll go to Gaza in
a minute which is even more serious no
one dies of thirst you can always buy
additional water water tankers readily
available and if you if you're able to
pay and it can be 10 times more
expensive than municipal water then of
course you have access to water but
people can be paying 20 30 % of their
income for water and again it depends on
the community so Ramallah gets water
twice a week Bethlehem in the summertime
will get water once every two or once
every three weeks Yatta further south in
the West Bank 110,000 people often get
water once every three months and that
means a sister it has to be built under
every home to store large quantities of
water until the next time water is
supplied and because the issue of water
remains so contentious and then the
other issues of the division of the West
Bank two areas a B and C sewage flows
everywhere and so every stream that
generally should be dry for most of the
year and only have winter rain water is
carrying sewage mostly Palestinian
sewage not being treated and it's
flowing either West to Israel or East to
pollute the Jordan River so we have a
real lose-lose situation and and then we
when we go to Gaza we see an absolute
tragedy a collapse of the groundwater so
this is the Gaza Strip there are 2
million people that live in the Gaza
Strip 40 kilometers by 10:00 at its
widest the aquifers carrying capacity is
about 50 million cubic meters annually
the close to four times that much he's
pumped out of the aquifer every year
which means that the aquifer has been
dropping and with the aquifer dropping
these red marks are sea water intrusion
salinity level salt levels of the of the
aquifer under Gaza can be a thousand
times higher than well World Health
Organization standards would permit for
drinking purposes and salt water rising
as the aquifer is is overdrawn but in
addition to the salinity there's also a
pollution so no modern Syrian plant
until very recently and we'll speak
about that in Gaza the sewage of 2
million people
percolating into the groundwater and
also flowing into the Mediterranean and
the
the drinkable water is really where the
green is but we're both greens so you
know geyser in 2017 that was the only
area of potable water in Gaza 3% of the
of the aquifer in 2019 were down to 1%
and basically people cannot be drinking
the groundwater at all gas has gone
right back to the Middle Ages people are
having to use jerrycans to fill water
from small desalination plants or water
imported from Israel and the groundwater
is simply no longer drinkable 1/3 of
disease in Gaza is related to a dirty
dirty water but the situation doesn't
just stop with the state of the aquifer
there's a hundred and ten million litres
of sewage raw or partly treated that
flows into the Mediterranean every day
every day and you know that has real
implications not only for the beaches of
Gaza but also upstream as the currents
move to Israel in these circumstances
the World Bank were trying to complete
the building of a new modern the first
modern surgery plant in Gaza and they
they wanted Israel to supply more
electricity and they needed cement and
this is 10 years in the this modern
searing plant cannot be completed it's a
white elephant and we have a
conversation with the bank and when we
think deeply well how can we turn this
around this is madness how could it be
when there is and when there's water
available when all the technologies in
place and yet the the construction can't
be completed cement can't get in because
Hamas at this time is stealing from
cement to build tunnels that then attack
Israel and
could sir fired at Israel the the the
the opinion the policy of the government
of Israel the time as well you know we
get rockets we're not going to supply
additional electricity we're not going
to supply additional water and we're not
going to allow cement in when we look at
this situation we think okay well this
is a ticking time bomb this is a ticking
time bomb
not only for two million Palestinians
living in Gaza but also for the
population in Israel and in Egypt and we
think well how can we turn this around
how can we bring common sense and we
start testing the beaches of Israel just
north of Gaza and just north of Gaza we
undertake testing here and we get test
results back and the laboratory tells us
there's good news
we haven't found cholera because we were
looking for cholera we thought that if
we find cholera that'll be a strong way
to to highlight to decision-makers that
we're all in the same boat but they told
us do you know that the desalination
plants are one of the five the most
southern desalination plant of Israel is
here in Ashkelon and they told us do you
know that Ashkelon is closed and of
course we didn't know because that was
kept as a secret because it wasn't
convenient to the policy of
disengagement that you know Israel had
left Gaza pulled out its settlements
pulled out its troops and built a wall
built a fence and what a throw away the
key yet and what we can see from these
satellite images which we also obtained
through Israel's foreign information law
was that you can't disengage this is
organic matter that's that's that that's
110 million leaders of cirrage and
moving with the currents north to
Ashkelon in fact all the way to Ashdod
and responsible for the closure
intermittently of 15% of israel's
drinking water and with the release of
that information and a complete
turnaround a understanding that indeed
the situation in Gaza and this is raw
sewage coming out of Gaza flowing into
Israel you know in a side Wadi that
should actually be completely dry but
this is black sewage this is the head of
the military responsible for cooperation
with Gaza and this is the u.s. spent
special envoy and these are mayor's from
the Israeli side all of the mayors along
the Israeli side around Gaza sent a
letter to the Prime Minister of Israel
to the Minister of Defense that we're at
the front line of rockets from Gaza of
tunnels from Gaza we don't want to be at
the front line of pandemic disease and
that really turns things around so the
whole policy of not allowing cementing
of not wanting to increase electricity
supplies and of not wanting to increase
water supplies is completely reversed
and the government of Israel becomes a
major seized not out of generosity but
out of self-interest the need to
stabilize Gaza through water and
sanitation and sees great risk to its
own population from the status quo so we
stand today in a situation where in fact
water as a whole is being held hostage
to the failure to move forward on other
final status issues so even though the
pie of water today would enable
Palestinians to obtain their fair share
of natural water resources both the
government of Israel and the government
of Palestine takes a position
that either we agree on all final status
issues Jerusalem borders settlements so
forth and water well we don't agree on
anything and we don't move forward on
anything so it's in this context today
that although the innovation is there
and the solution is is not happening
because the whole context is an
all-or-nothing approach we see some some
changes on the field so this is the
Palestinian Minister of water the past
the Israeli minister of regional
cooperation and the former American
envoi they sign an agreement on the sale
of additional water from Israel to
Palestine but of course that's not what
it's all about an acre piece we see a
real opportunity that water is a low
hanging fruit that can improve the
reality on the ground for every
Palestinian and also for every Israeli
without any losers because additional
water supply can be replaced today
through relatively cheap manufactured
water and even more to the point when we
come to an agreement on one of the five
final status issues we can say to the
public well we have a partner because
for the most part the majority of
Israelis and the majority of
Palestinians believe that they have no
partner believe that there's no one to
deal with that we can't strike a deal on
anything and there's no wonder that the
help that they have that opinion because
the paradigm for the last 25 years has
been an all-or-nothing paradigm and in
that sense water presents an opportunity
to break that paradigm and this is one
of the reports of air cupisz that
describe that and this is one of the
very many foreign ministers of Foreign
Minister of Finland and who would try to
work with in order to
get the international community which
also has adopted an all-or-nothing
approach you'll be at the Obama
administration the Clinton
administration or the Trump
administration they've all kept you know
the belief that we have to sold
everything or we don't solve anything
and that's left us for 25 years with
actually holding today water hostage so
that's one of the points that I want to
speak to and I'm careful of time the
second is to look at the broader
innovation on particularly you're
looking at climate change and the
threats that climate change posed to the
broader region and again how innovation
in the water sector coupled with
innovation in renewable energy can be a
real game-changer for the region as well
and and and move the region from it from
the example of bloodshed and violence to
a region perhaps that can lead the rest
of the world on issues of climate
mitigation and climate adaptation so the
relationship between water security and
national security is not new and you
know the Europeans and the UN have been
talking about it for many years but
interestedly
most recently NATO starts to talk about
it the US government in fact under the
trap administration released a u.s.
global water strategy and the water
strategy speaks to water insecurity
mostly in the Middle East and being
identified as a threat to US national
security interests very important
linking the relationship of water
insecurity and national security
concerns when we look at the Menna
region the Middle East North Africa
well we actually see the most water
insecure part of the world there is
nowhere in this planet that has a
greater water insecurity than Middle
East North Africa and you also see that
region suffers from a tremendous amount
of
of conflicts it's not to say that
there's a direct relationship but many
of the conflicts in the Middle East do
have a level of animosity related to
water insecurity you know with its
economic impacts with its health impacts
with its development impacts and then
you look at climate change and you have
even greater reason for concern
so the IPCC identifies the many region
as a climate hot spot here in the united
states and western europe and the
concern is one and a half two degrees
increase in temperature well we're
already experiencing a two degree
increase in temperature we're worried
about a four and five degree increase in
temperature we're worried that large
tracts of the men of region will no
longer be livable because temperatures
will be so high for so many months that
the human body cannot sustain itself
with forty five degrees for six months
of the year Celsius forty five degrees
and and and that's underlying a
situation where we're already over
drawing from our aquifers so in 2015 you
know close to 300 million cubic meters
mostly Jordan Palestine being overdrawn
were drinking our children and our
grandchildren's waters you know within a
decade close to 600 million and this is
just for domestic purposes I'm not even
talking about agriculture over drawing
all of our aquifers were drinking the
waters of future generations in a
situation of diminishing return with
precipitation is is forecast to drop by
after 40 percent and latest figures and
this is coming out of Tel Aviv
University within the end of the century
you know summertime will increase by 50
percent the summer months we lose
rainfall completely in the
november/december period you know
already within the middle of the century
you know the forecasts the models of the
eye
PCC for the men a region were all wrong
because they underestimated and the
latest models will perhaps these are
going to be wrong to perhaps they're
also under estimating because the
forecast as we see is a scary forecast
for the region and that doesn't
necessarily mean more conflict much
depends on the adaptive capacity of of
governments of societies but given that
the region is so conflict prone given
the number of failed or new failed
States that we have in the region the
prospects and do not look positive for
climate change and then increased
hostilities and instability within
countries and between countries our
three countries do have plans so Jordan
has her strategies Palestine hers Israel
has hers as well but there's next to no
integration here this looks to no
cooperation and that's something that
that we've identified in our reports as
a as a missing link that we're not going
to be able to cope with the challenges
of climate change unless cooperation is
inherent and integrated into the system
just to show you how severe things are
for the Sea of Galilee so this is from
the hydrological survey of Israel a
hundred years of documentation for the
Sea of Galilee in the last 20 years we
see 15 years of drought the longest and
deepest droughts that the region has
ever known there's no parallel
throughout the hundred years of
of of evidence documented to what's
happened in these last 20 years and last
summer the Sea of Galilee threatened to
potentially turn from a freshwater lake
to a salen lake two islands appear in
the middle of the Sea of Galilee and in
order to respond to that and Israel
actually does something that you know
earlier generations ben-gurion would
have sort of turned in his grave so the
national water carrier that was built in
the 60s 50s and 60s that took water from
the Sea of Galilee and would bring it to
the center of the country and down to
the Negev in these in these pipes is
today being reversed in these last years
20 to 30 million cubic meters is all
that's pumped out of the Sea of Galilee
where while in the past there was 350
million cubic meters and today the five
desalination plants are linked to the
national water carrier and this pipe is
being laid in the last stretch that
would bring desalinated water to the Sea
of Galilee to prevent the sea of
gallilee turning into the Dead Sea and
to make sure that Israel's commitment of
supplying water to Jordan and is
maintained not again out of generous
generosity but out of fear that further
insecurity in Jordan will lead to
instability there and that's indeed the
next slide that that speaks to you know
the situation for Jordan being one of
the most water scarce countries on earth
already so perhaps the second or third
most water scarce country on earth that
is already heavily dependent on the
peace treaty agreement of 55 million
cubic meters has suffered from Syria
taking additional water from the Yarmouk
after Jordan and Israel signed a peace
treaty
so Syria punishes Jordan by preventing
more water to flow down the Yarmouk at
Jordan's expense
and very serious management issues in
Jordan so 50% of the water in the
capital Amman is lost through either
theft or leaking pipes through you know
lack of investment and a lot of money
being a lot a lot of ideas and hope for
the future in Jordan placed on the idea
of building a canal from the Red Sea the
Dead Sea something has been talked about
for the last 25 years but nothing has
moved forward and an increasing fear on
the part of Jordan of being increasingly
dependent on Israel and you can see some
of the cooperation that takes place
between Israel and Jordan even prior to
signing the peace treaty so cooperation
between Jordanians and at that time
Jewish immigrants to Palestine in the
building of the first dam and the
hydroelectric station on the Jordan and
the Yarmouk in the 20s and 30s that
produce 40 percent of the electricity of
Mandate Palestine and then the different
agreements and the late King Hussein and
were been signing one of the annexes on
the shores of the Sea of Galilee a Red
Dead Agreement that's never moved
forward a water swap agreement involving
also Palestine here Palestinian Minister
Jordanian Minister Israeli Minister but
nothing has actually moved forward and
the situation for Jordan is of course
the same as a situation from Israel so
this is Stanford University data it's
only from the 70s but again it shows you
for the last 20 years the deepest
droughts again that the region and the
longest routes that the region has ever
known that situation of course is not
just as shared for Israel and Jordan
it's also shared in southern Syria and
it helps explain part of the underlying
cause for the uprising not the only and
perhaps not the main but the fact that
the Assad regime didn't respond to the
consecutive year
of drought meant that hundreds of
thousands of farmers in Syria had to
leave their land because their land
became a dust bowl of desert instead of
Syria being a major exporter or an
exporter of wheat and the whole region
gets dry and people move to the towns
like Java where the uprising starts
because millions of people lose their
livelihood and it's it's in that context
that not only the uprising in Syria and
the devastation takes place in Syria but
real implications for Jordan ex-delta
next door so the refugee camps on the
border of Syria and Jordan and Jordan
officially receiving about a million
refugees unofficially perhaps two
million refugees and that has direct
implications for water security of
Jordan so this is a man and everywhere
in Jordan like everywhere in Palestine
there's no 24/7 water supply only Israel
has 24/7 water supply in the Levant
countries and water is supplied before
the refugee crisis in a man 2 days a
week after the refugees arrive in a man
Easter man which is the poorer areas
received water for 12 hours a week and
the wealthier part of the man gets water
for 24 hours just one day so a 50% cut
and more in water supply and leading
again to animosity and potential
instability when we look at the Jordan
Valley the breadbasket and for Jordanian
agriculture and food production here too
with reduced precipitation we see
farmers leaving their land we see also
with the borders close to Iraq to Syria
know where to sell goods and resulting
in you know very high levels of
unemployment and 50% are youth
unemployment and that again leads to
instability because young men with no
prospects of ever
getting a job have also no prospects of
ever getting married in traditional
cultures and a very prone to be
susceptible to radical ideologies and
jordan was a major hunting ground for
isis very successfully in bringing Isis
fighters from Jordan it's in that
context that again we see the
possibilities of innovation making a
difference innovation in the water and
energy sector and in this case learning
from the experience of Europe because
the Middle East is not the only part of
the world that seen a hundred years of
violence in fact Europe saw many hundred
years of violence and tremendous loss of
life yet after World War two one of the
key agreements that brought stability to
the continent was the coal and steel
agreement an agreement that forced the
cooperation on the two most important
natural resources of the European
continent coal and steel and cooperation
that wood was there was plan to make war
and you know impossible again Germany
could never you know build its war
machine because the coal and steel
integral industry would be integrated
Europe wide and Attica peace with the
support of the Conrad and that shift or
a foundation from Germany associated
with the the ruling party the CDU we try
to draw a lesson to what what are the
key natural resources of the Levant that
perhaps we can also force integration
over and we looked at that again at the
innovation of harnessing the see through
desalination and that is as you saw
earlier proven technology in fact all
private sector-led as well so it doesn't
even need you know generosity of the
donor community and and that both Israel
and Palestine in fact share the
advantage of desalination on the
Mediterranean coast and because all of
the main population centers in Israel in
Palestine and in Jordan are 100
kilometres from the Mediterranean while
Jordan also has a sea and candy salad 8
but Aqaba is 300 kilometers from Amman
its second city is 400 kilometers from
the Red Sea and of course that means
that the water is three or four times
more expensive Jordan on the other hand
has proven investments in proven
capacity for harnessing the Sun and the
game change here is really China's entry
into photovoltaics because with China's
mass production of photovoltaic cells
we've seen a dramatic drop in the cost
of producing renewable energy through
photovoltaics so Jordan is today
producing electricity at 3 cents a
kilowatt-hour that's the cheapest
electricity available during the day in
Israel electricity is 10 to 11 cents a
kilowatt hour so again it's not an issue
of generosity and it's not an issue of
looking for development funds and
Jordans investment in the field is all
led by the private sector with a profit
motive and as an engine behind this
development and Israel has the Negev and
it's seen as well ok Israel can also
invest in large scale renewables but
half the negative is military training
and the other hand the other half are
declared nature reserves Israel is only
at 4 percent renewables it's not meeting
its parish targets Jordan will mean it's
Paris targets ahead of time and
therefore Jordan has the comparative
advantage over Israel and Palestine very
difficult for renewable and energy in a
mountainous area in a hilly
the West Bank and of course Gaza is so
crowded that there's there's no room for
any large scale renewables so Jordan has
the comparative advantage and in doing
so well what we achieve is water
security for all three countries so at
the moment only Israel has water
security but if you know with the
building of desalination plants in Gaza
and the powering of that desalination
through Seoul are coming from Jordan
than all three countries can achieve
water security all three countries can
move to energy security through and
every country having something to sell
and every country having something to
buy the Jordanian is having electricity
to sell that creates a revenue stream
that enables them to buy desalinated
water from Israel and Palestine and the
desalinated water produced through
renewables creates a revenue stream for
Palestine and Israel to buy electricity
and that then creates an a that promotes
regional stability very much like coal
and steel has so successfully done in
these last 70 years and with the
creation of of the European Union and
further it also helps us advance and
again expanding the pie so the
Palestinians can achieve their water
rights of getting their fair share of
the natural water and shared with Israel
this is not a pipe dream and we already
see aspects of this concept being
implemented and the study the
pre-feasibility study gives it a green
light and you can read about it and also
the climate impacts but water is already
flowing east so with the peace treaty
commitment israel supplies fifty five
million from the sea of galilee in a
pipe that goes to the king abdullah
canal and supplies water to ear bid
supplies water to
man with the reversal of the national
water carrier we're desalination plants
in Gaza and in Israel could all be
connected and pump additional water
Israel alone is planning to pump some
300 million cubic meters of water into
the Sea of Galilee not just to protect
the Sea of Galilee but out of concern of
national security along its eastern
border so that Jordan would be able to
have more relatively cheap water and
Jordan is already a leader in renewables
with some 650 megawatts of installed
power in the South another 200 megawatts
installed in the north and in fact a
tech apiece we've received a grant to
build the first solar pilot station that
would sell electricity across the border
and we're literally waiting for a new
government in Jerusalem and to
facilitate to enable that to happen and
this is last month at the UN climate
summit where we're asked to present this
very proposal as an example of climate
mitigation and climate adaptation that
is relevant not only to Israel Palestine
and Jordan it could be really a model
that in the future could include Syria
and Lebanon and Egypt and the broader
Middle East and other areas where it
makes sense to integrate the coast and
the hinterland in a manner that creates
healthy interdependencies
so water innovation energy innovation
creates opportunities for us in an area
of the world where there are very few
opportunities and in this effort we're
hoping that you know we're going to be
able to balance ourselves these are
Israeli Palestinian and Jordanian youth
all coming with the same message water
has no borders water issues cannot wait
and water innovation is our low-hanging
fruit and were determined
Bekka piece to make sure that this
low-hanging fruit changers helps change
our reality on the ground not in another
decade not together with everything else
but reflecting the urgency in the need
of bringing that change tomorrow and
just grateful for the opportunity to
present it here at Yale and again thank
you for listening and I I think I open
up for the questions that you and others
have been doing to try and fix it I want
to remind people
okay please in the back so our strategy
is to first of all present the
information to the public to present it
in a manner that doesn't speak of a
blame but speaks to take responsibility
and speaks to the lose/lose of the
current situation so we've been able to
reverse the situation for Gaza you know
by highlighting that the that the status
quo was a security risk for all sides
and that changed the the policies of in
this case the government of Israel where
cement has now been removed so that sir
shroom plant it took another two years
to complete it but the second modern
surgery plant in Gaza will be finished
either at the end of this year or the
beginning of next year and has taken
only four years to build so so by
highlighting the
water issues are security issues not in
the military sets but in a broader human
security perspective that we're all on
the Titanic and whether we're on first
class or you know sort of under the how
when the when the iceberg hits we all
sink you know that that's what this
drawing is all about this is what we're
is what the kids are portraying and we
found that the security argument is a
very effective argument in Israel that
the water rights argument is a very
effective argument in Palestine and the
development argument is very effective
in Jordan so you know our strategy is
for Israelis to speak Hebrew on security
to Israelis and Palestinians in Arabic
on rights issues to Palestinians and
Jordanians in Arabic on development
issues but all in that same framework of
trying to change the paradigm by
highlighting the self-interest and but
nevertheless in a way that advances
mutual gain this report the one before
on climate change and is the result of a
set of three roundtables a round table
in Ramallah with Palestinian decision
makers on climate change and national
security a round table in a man a
separate round table in Tel Aviv that
culminates in a regional round table and
at the end of 2018 where officials from
Israel Palestine and Jordan don't agree
on many many issues but they're coming
around the table all fearful of cut of
climate change all fearful that what
they see is happening in front of their
eyes threatens their their national
security interests the the very
viability of the vision that that each
that each side has in the expression of
a
national agenda and therefore they come
together and therefore perhaps unlike
here in the United States there's really
no dispute on climate change issues
between our respective governments
there's a common fear and we need to
utilize that common fear to move forward
on what is urgent to all three so that
that's part of that so another strategy
that we employ is working with the
various stakeholders that have an
interest in region and you know the
River Jordan is wholly to half of
humanity to the three Abrahamic faiths
and we've tried to bring attention of
religious leadership that the conflict
has led to turning this river you know
Holly in different perspectives but
nevertheless Holly to all three faiths
into little more than a sewage canal and
religious leadership has stood up and
you know not just the mayor's but but
also leaders of the Jewish Christian and
Muslim faith and have signed a covenant
together on the River Jordan have been
you know participating in activities
both in the region and outside the
region and in February the first week of
February as part of un harmony week
we'll probably have a hundred religious
leaders touring the Jordan River
together to bring attention
to bring the different faith-based
traditions that we're all losing
something and we you know we don't need
to be we could be turning this around
and that's that's another aspect of of
creating political will on this issue
you know against the status quo which is
clearly a critical part of that strategy
the lady of the back so so there's
political instability in all three
countries unfortunately and when we
start discussions with the minister
often in the middle you know the
government will be changed it's it's
pretty unusual that a government stays
in power for more than 12 months in
Jordan there's there's you know talk of
of elections and the in Palestine there
are two governments that don't speak to
each other and that's a major issue and
clearly also in Israel with you know
these last this last year where there's
just caretaker governments in place and
we might be seeing a third round of
elections because of you know the
inability to reach a coalition of
consensus and the implications is delay
for us so we're waiting we we actually
have money in our bank account to build
a pilot solar facility in Jordan and we
need the the agreement of both countries
of Israel and Jordan here and although
the Minister of Energy in Israel
supports the the building of the pilot
he can't issue the letter because
there's a caretaker government that
would be a new policy and caretaker
governments cannot issue new policies
electricity has never crossed the border
there is no standard in place for the
purchase of electricity from another
country so
that's a very concrete example of
something that's holding us up today and
we're waiting for for a new government
we also you know hoping that we'll have
a new prime minister because the
relationship between the you know
Netanyahu and and the king of Jordan is
incredibly bad and you know we need a
new leadership in place and in order to
improve that relationship so that we
don't see the continuation of a downward
spiral as we saw on the you know the
renewal of two annexes that relate to
the Israel Jordan peace tree so the
instability of government causes great
delay on the other hand I think what is
common for all three governments is
rarely do they speak in one voice so
something that I haven't talked about is
that we're often condemned
we're always condemned we're always seen
as traitors and you know whether it's
the Israeli office that seen as working
with and therefore it's working for or
the Palestinian office or the Judean
office and we always come across
ministers that will refuse to work with
us but the good news is that we always
find ministers in all three governments
that are willing to work with us and the
fact that that the government's are
generally made you know through a
coalition that is you know precarious
but on the other hand creates
opportunities for us to work with
ministers that don't necessarily agree
with other ministers that will refuse to
work with us so there's pros and cons to
that instability as well please
greater integration so so the
feasibility you know it depends on the
political will the economic feasibility
is very strongly there and and the
pre-feasibility study shows that the
fact that we have private sector
investors that are knocking on our door
that are wanting to move forward speaks
to the economic viability in fact in the
building of the of new desalination
plant so the red are either doubling
existing or new desalination plants they
were approached by the private sector
how can they buy the cheaper that
electricity the green electricity from
Jordan because of course it's it's so
much cheaper than existing electricity
in Israel which is fossil you know which
is mostly natural gas today so so the
the the creation of at least
relationships of water and energy have
strong economic engines we see you know
the agreements that are in place our
agreements that have strong economic
engine so you know Israel sells natural
gas found in the Mediterranean and
supplies it to the potash the Arab
polish on the jury inside and he's now
supplying it for the production of
electricity in Jordan and the reason
that you know Jordan is buying that is
because the cost is half of any other
alternative for them so the economics
even though there are demonstrations in
Amman most Friday's calling people
calling on people to live in the dark
rather than be purchasing natural gas
from Israel the government purchased the
natural gas because its debt increases
every day by not used
the cheaper natural gas from Israel and
so there are powerful economic
incentives that were at the heart of the
creation of the European Union and we
need to remember that you know the
French and the Germans didn't love each
other and probably until today don't
love each other yet they know how to
work together and and you know the
beauty of the idea of a water renewable
energy Nexus is that we create these
healthy interdependencies where we're
not we're not dependent on being nice to
each other we're not depending on on
being generous to one another we're
dependent on our own national security
cooperating with our neighbors and I
don't know whether it'll lead to a
European Union but we do see so we see
cooperation on natural gas and between
Israel Egypt Cyprus Jordan taking place
today so you know the seeds of very much
there we need greater political will you
know to bring this forth and we we are
we remain optimistic because the
economics and the environment is so
powerful and this is the cheapest way
for all three countries to meet there
Paris commitments sorry so so so it
doesn't come instead of a so we strongly
believe in a two-state solution it
doesn't come instead of yes yes so you
know this is not a this is not a an
argument for an economic piece and we
still need a political piece but an
economic piece based on sort of
sustainability and mechanisms can
underpin that political piece so we
think that both are needed so please
West Coast are privately invested in and
quality the majority of the electricians
to the US being developed in the solar
plants and Jordan is privately invested
in and you're already pumping water up
backwards in this system so the only
missing link is the ability to purchase
electricity so absolutely so firstly the
desalination plants four out of the five
a private sector there is one that was
built in Ashdod and that was built by
mikata government company and it didn't
do very well it's about to be sold and
then all the additional desalination
plants are also private sector all of
the renewable in Jordan is also private
sector mostly Gulf Gulf funds and as you
said water is crossing there is a little
bit of electricity crossing from from
Jordan to Palestine to Jericho not to
Israel and Jordan is part of the arab
grid there's an arab boycott of selling
electricity to Israel and Jordan can't
break that because it requires the
agreement of Syria Iraq Lebanon and I
won't give their agreement the beauty of
renewables is that you don't need to
link it to the grid so you can build and
renewable energy solar farms in Jordan
and you know carry our line directly to
Israel and you don't breach and the Arab
League boycott again you know part of
the ingenuity of
the the technology and and you know and
again the beauty of the technology is
modular you can start you know so our
pre-feasibility study shows that you
know if twenty percent of the
electricity from Israel is purged in
Israel is purchased from Jordan that
produces a revenue stream that enables
Jordan to buy all the water she needs
and still leaves a billion dollars
annually in the budget
it increases Jordans GDP by four percent
and becomes you know one of the major
industries of the country but you don't
need to start with twenty percent
because you know the government of
Israel will feel highly insecure in the
beginning to be dependent on 20% of her
electricity from Jordan you can start
with something much less and grow with
time and that's that's again the beauty
of the technology that continues to
improve so if you build in a modular
fashion you build trust and with more
trust you can increase the exchange of
water and energy between the countries
and and that's why we think that you
know the all-or-nothing approach is so
poisonous to the region because if we
have to agree on everything before we
move forward on anything then there's no
wonder that was move forward on nothing
in these last 25 years so so much of the
change that needs to take place needs to
be a political paradigm change of how we
make peace and when we look at Northern
Ireland Northern Ireland didn't make
peace you know there's a Good Friday
Agreement but there were many other
agreements in its path why does Israel
Palestine peace have to be all or
nothing that's not the example of
peacemaking in other parts of the world
and-and-and here is a real possibility
and because of changes in technology to
change that paradigm please
[Music]
president uses so it all depends on on
the extent of over drawing and so the
coastal aquifer and the Gaza is pretty
much dead the Israel completely controls
how much water Palestinians can extract
from the West Bank portions of the mouth
knock refer and you know if if
Palestinians build additional wells
visual cells sends in the military to
destroy those wells to destroy those
pumping stations so because Israel takes
the lion's share of this cross-border
aquifer and Israel prevents over drawing
on the Palestinian side in the past
Israel had over pumped the aquifer
itself but today with desalination its
withdraw it's reduced and it's pumping
so so sure it's very much an unsolved
issue and and while there isn't there's
real control of over drawing the aquifer
there is no control of the sewage and
the sewage is flowing and contaminating
the shared groundwater that Israel takes
the lion's share and one of the reports
and that I'd highlighted earlier was
trying an echo peace report was trying
to highlight
the policies of the government of Israel
not serving her her own long long term
interests in on the whole issue of how
cirrage and the building of surgery
plants are difficult for the
Palestinians and that you know every
cubic meter of sewage that flows for
instance in in this stream there's this
surge from the Nablus area in fact today
there is a sewage treatment plant but
just south of of Nablus there's raw sory
to the treated sewage is not being used
significantly for agriculture on the
Palestinian side and then it's mixed
with raw sewage then when it crosses the
Green Line
it goes into a certain plant on the
Israeli side but half of this of the
pollution seeps into the ground water
before it reaches the Green Line and
then Israel charges the Palestine
Authority for every cubic meter of
sewage of treats but it charges Ramallah
you know a government level the
municipalities on the Palestinian side
therefore have no incentive to really
treat their sewage because the the
national government is paying for it and
they're getting almost a disincentive so
again you know the way governance takes
place is critical to sustainable
solutions yes
in terms of their willingness to change
so very much so you see young people no
longer committed to a two-state solution
on both camps I mean both the
Palestinian Street and the Israeli
Street I think particularly on the
Palestinian side where there's a
complete loss of of hope that they'll
ever be a Palestinian state and concern
that you know the economic situation is
so bad
and we see that also in Jordan with with
such high rates of unemployment that a
one-state solution seems far more
attractive to to match in the
Palestinian street where people are much
more concerned about getting jobs and
giving a better lifestyle and they see
quite high levels of prosperity on the
Israeli side and think that okay well
you know a one-state solution will
service will service much better you
know and you know at least at least at
the piece we think that the the only way
to meet the national aspirations of both
peoples is a two-state solution and a
one-state solution might be an apartheid
solution or might be a Lebanon solution
which is you know communal warfare all
the time so we don't think that that is
the solution at all and and you know the
bottom line is that we must give hope to
young people the the 25 years of all or
nothing and the failure to move forward
has taken away a sense of hope for the
young generation and that needs to be
returned urgently please
the past 20 years what how would you
like the American any boy or in that
administration seems like the EU is
already pretty much on board with the
American administration to treat this so
it's interesting that that every lead
negotiator on the American side while
they're leading the negotiations whether
it's a Democrat or a public
I've been absolutely certain that
they're gonna strike the deal and
therefore the attitude has been no you
know war is not as it's not important
enough we can solve everything so let's
solve everything and it's almost at our
reach and then when they leave the
administration they'll often tell us
yeah it's a pity we didn't solve water
so how do we break that because we now
have you know three lead negotiators
that have come and said to us after the
fact it's a pity we didn't solve water
and so so highlighting that you know
three former American lead negotiators
now have the opinion that they regret
not so not solving the water issue is
something that we speak to this
administration about the dis certainty
that the agreement is around the corner
you know hasn't proven itself you know
over these last 25 years and then the
cost of not reaching that agreement on
water is rising and and that's
particularly the case with climate
change now with in with visit this
current American administration you
can't talk about climate change but you
can talk about water insecurity and the
US has a national security policy on
water insecurity with Jordan being
very very much present as an issue of
concern and the broader Middle East as
an issue of Prada of concern so we can
bring those discussions to bear that is
going to require a new government in
Jerusalem and we're waiting for that new
government to be formed
[Applause]
[Music]